hey drew my name is monasie and i have
been seeing these beautiful weathered
vases everywhere in store and
unfortunately they cost hundreds and
hundreds of dollars which is insane so i
was wondering if you know how i can make
one of those weathered vases at home for
a fraction of the price thanks drew
here to help with modesty's design
dilemma is celebrity interior designer
and drew crew member it's michael welch
hello
um
mikal can you just list a few of the
clients that you've worked with um
michelle obama oprah winfrey uh tyler
perry uh steve harvey right
and if you open a veranda an
architectural digest a house beautiful
and el decor all of my favorite
magazines in the world mikal is right
there front and center
and it's always an honor to work with
someone who is as esteemed as you are
because sometimes when i do look in
those magazines i look at the prices of
things and i get sticker shock i do too
i do too but luckily i started off as a
set decorator so i know the hacks okay
so yes i love when you give us
budget-friendly diy approaches because
that's something we can all buy into
absolutely and these weathered vases are
like all the rage so how do we do this
macaulay all right so let's jump right
into it so i've started out everybody
knows i love like craigslist thrift
stores et cetera i started out with a
very inexpensive vase the next thing
that you want to do is take your
paintbrush and you just want to give
your base a nice coat of textured paint
now here's the fun thing drew you don't
have to like be a picasso like honestly
you can just go random with it and just
like have your way
go all the way around and just keep
going
and what's going to end up happening is
you've got this kind of like loosely
layered light paint that goes all across
the top of this piece here so now
your vase should start to look like this
as it begins to drop
um so now you can go ahead and put that
one down okay i'm gonna show you the
next piece all right so now we're gonna
get a little dirty so this is literally
like no money at all we're gonna go
outside we're gonna grab a scoop of dirt
and literally mix it with a little bit
of water now bear with me on this one
but we're going to take clumps of the
dirt
and we are going to begin pack it on
pack it on and you want to go right onto
those painted surfaces so here so here's
the thing with it don't go super crazy
right i don't want you to have like a
full like layer of this like it's all
caked up but just go really
girl what are you over there doing
i i yo we'll get there we'll get there
you know me mikael
i mean literally i'm like this with
everything it's like i'm a lot you know
i know i'm gonna be your design
therapist i'm gonna help you pull back a
little bit so i'm gonna say that you can
go ahead and place that down for a
second wipe your hands off
so once we allow the piece to dry this
is what the beauty will look like now
keep this in mind as you're allowing the
piece to dry what you slowly want to do
is you begin to remove off some of the
dirt and you want to go really slow
what's going to happen is over time as
it's beginning to dry the layers will
start to peel off and then they will
have that smooth patina that you want
well it's kind of like a textured smooth
patina so it's sort of in a weird way
like sponge paint but
mcgee does it they all do it and it's
like more expensive but joanna gaines
does it i am into it exactly
exactly look at that i mean
there's no bigger girl crush i have than
miss joanna kane and so now you can put
your foliage like right into the vase
and make a little arrangement
oh and i'm super cute feeling
super cute i think this is so beautiful
i mean
and this you know other than my
approach was very easy
um i i love this look i love it mikael
um we'll have these diy instructions for
your own weathered base on the
drewberrymore show.com
but get yourself a little greenery
and lift your mood thank you
[Music]
you